foreign
Toledo hi Jeff welcome to the Ramsey
Show
hey Dave thank you for taking my call my
friend I just want to tell you right up
front that uh
um your riveting message has meant a lot
to my family over years and we did FPU
about 14 years ago changed my life
changed my family tree thank you for
that honored thank you
no problem
um my main question is I think I did a
little bit of a boo-boo Dave and I'm I'm
kind of retracting from it and and I I I
have a feeling that your answer is going
to end up being not exactly what you
want to say or what's best interest for
me and my family and here's why so
basically my wife passed away about a
year and a half ago of ovarian cancer
wonderful Christian woman I'm sorry um
she was a warrior she was she was she
went through FPU with me many years ago
it wasn't necessarily her strength I was
the nerd and family and and took care of
the finances but she
while during this cancer Journey says I
think we I need to leave a legacy for
our adult children our upcoming adult
children
and I said well how do you feel you want
to do this she said I think we need to
go to the title lawyer and include our
kids in on the on the and do a quick
claim deed and include them in on 25 of
the equity in our home which we have 100
equity on a home in Findlay Ohio that's
uh Worth right about between 750 and
800k
so I really don't uh so what I did is I
was in the midst of uh
really all hands on deck with her
ovarian cancer journey and it was very
difficult and I wasn't really in my
right mind and I signed it
and I think that
um releasing this money because I'm
actually getting married to a wonderful
gal from Dallas Texas and she's
incredible we have a long distance
relationship long story short I really
feel that I'm putting the house up on
the market and we've already got a
couple potential buyers
um I know the children are my daughter's
18 senior in high school and my son is
21 down in in Orlando and uh so
basically what what's going to happen is
when we sell this home we're going to
get to the tune of about 175k to 200k
each
and I feel like it's going to be it's
not going to teach them the right things
um yes they each got 25 percent
yes I signed the quick claim deed you
didn't give them a quarter you gave them
a quarter each
a quarter each so you can sell it for
800 okay 200 Grand yeah I got you okay
all right and um I feel like it's
teaching them the wrong message and if
they get they're getting a windfall at a
very young age now granted they have the
right to do what they want with the
money
and I wanted to get your opinion on is
it is am I not a man of principle if I
if I try to retract this and let get
them signed back off of it
before we fill this house or is it a
good idea to just follow through with my
commitment that I made with my wife
because she wanted to leave a legacy for
our kids
um
trying to think what I would do a good
way to solve ethics questions is get on
the other side and walk in the moccasins
treat other people like you'd want to be
treated kind of thing and so um I do not
hear you wanting to take this money and
buy your new wife a Mercedes I hear you
uh worried about your kids being
burdened with the weight of this that's
what I heard you say and so you are
putting their best interest at heart so
that does not make you lacking in
principle it makes you quite the
opposite
um what would I do if I were in your
shoes uh
because we do want to carry this Equity
into their our home that we want to live
we want to live in Atlanta I think what
I would do for sure is
um I would do a will immediately
and uh and a prenup
that protects their portion
uh were you to pass
okay and so and then I would ask them I
would ask them to get it back to you and
then you say I'm going to leave you
all of the money from this house if I
die
and at a later Point
um you know as you guys get a little bit
older I'm going to help you with some
other things anyway but you're going to
end up getting this all the money from
the house not just of fourth each you're
going to get a 50 each when I die and uh
because I'm going to protect that with a
prenup and I'm going to protect that
with a will
but my children are pretty bound and
determined to get this money Dave oh
well that's they're not going to sign
the quit claim if they don't want to
sign the quick claim they really want to
sign it they don't want to sign it they
don't you can't make them sign it yeah
I'm worried about the relational I'm
worried about the relation last but I
think Dave's right you know put yourself
in your kids shoes to the best of your
ability to say you've told them this
this was your this was their mothers
dying wish you told them it was going to
happen and now you're changing your mind
and we're not questioning the principle
of the change but you have to put
yourself in their shoes and what is this
going to do to your relationship and I
think you have to consider that because
that to me is the bigger long-term issue
yeah yeah you add it you added color to
this equation when you said they didn't
want to do it that was the first part
first time in the conversation we heard
that part so that does change now again
they're going based on hey this is our
mother's wishes this is what we see
because it was now I was a little queasy
well I don't care you did I wasn't in my
right mind yeah you did it
um I did it yeah this would have been
the good time for the nerd to say no
thank you that's a bad plan
uh they're going to get it all when I
they're going to get it all when I die
anyway and no I'm not giving it giving
them a fourth of the quick claim sorry
you know that would have been the
conversation at our house but you know
so that's water under the bridge now now
you got two kids that are expecting this
and don't want to sign the quit claim
you are going to step in a relationship
hole here
uh and rightly so but I don't think it's
a matter of you're a man of principle
that's not the point uh the the point is
more the relational thing that's going
to get violated here and so I think I
think they got the money dude I think
you screwed up
I'm sorry no yeah that my title lawyer
just told me the same thing well there's
no question from a title standpoint you
can't do nothing but I was early in the
conversation I was under the impression
you could get them to be willing to sign
the title back over to you and now
you're saying they don't want to do that
well that's that you can't make them
is it wrong for me to persuade them and
get counsel to reverse that so that we
don't
you know what a what a tangled where we
could weave here if you can persuade
them without them thinking their dad's a
dog that's the issue you got to be
careful because they may think you talk
about money here and it you just said
they think this was their mom's dying
wish and you know you're going to get
now you're fighting with angels
do you want your kids thinking that
you're greedy
that's the risk no absolutely not and I
will tell you I will tell you I think
that's the reason a little the tail
wagging the dog here yeah I the only
thing I would probably do here is say
listen if you all don't want me to
handle this for you
because it was your mother's dying wish
I understand that I I really think it's
unwise for you to get 200 000 is 18
years old I'm your dad I love you and I
think it's gonna be a problem for you
rather than a blessing but I can't I I'm
not going to go back on my word if you
choose to give me this quarterback I
will protect you on it but if you don't
want to do that
um then I'm not gonna I'm not certainly
not going to force it I am going to do
my best as your dad to persuade you to
do smart things and not let this be a
problem for you but um but yeah it was a
um
you know it's horrible to say in this
situation but it's really dumb idea I
mean it's just uh but you're stuck with
it now and yeah you can't force this you
can't go in before the judge and go uh
your honor we want you to reverse this
because I really wasn't thinking clearly
that one won't work yeah right the judge
is going to go whoops sorry about that
stupid Text time so yeah hopefully you
can just persuade them uh that their
best interest is at heart and if you
can't then persuade them to do something
wise and let you help them help lead
them to good decisions with the money
but I think the money's probably gone
but it sounds like to me